it is very bad it's the worst i've ever  seen it  yeah the one before it went far beyond  it but this in my opinion is the worst  it is a reminder that  in the face of the raw power of nature  human beings are really quite small  and therefore we need to do what we can  to protect people as i say to invest  more in flood defense and that's a  responsibility for the whole of society  and i hope that the government will  respond to the demands undoubtedly that  they will  get but you look at a place like  carlisle which had devastating floods in  the past  new flood defenses uh went in and  they hadn't been enough to keep out the  the rising flood waters so it shows that  we need to go back and reassess what  needs to be done  but to realize that we are living in  changing times when it comes to the  weather